[Musique]
xavi merci merci à tous est là pour
cette deuxième journée au parc floral de
paris pour cette belle rentrée les
jeunes républicains j invite sur scène
quand un carmen irène weiss emma
thomasson vous pouvez les appeler un
très fort ils vont vous restituer les
ateliers les tables rondes d'hier vous
pouvez l'applaudir
[Musique]
commençons avec quentin quentin tu va
animer la table ronde sur la question de
protéger sur la question de l'autorité
de l'état et la protection des plus
faibles exactement merci il aime merci à
tous bonjour à tous j'espère que vous
avez passé une bonne soirée
alors je vais vous faire un petit bilan
de ce qui s'est dit sur notre table
ronde rassembler d'abord je voudrais
remercier les plus de 400 jeunes qui
étaient présents à cette table ronde
leur présence chaleureuse leurs
questions pertinentes et leurs
réflexions intéressantes ont permis à
nos invités julien aubert valérie boyer
philippe juvin et eric ciotti avec qui
j'ai pu discuter qui qui s'était excusé
de ne pas pouvoir être là de développer
leurs pensées leurs opinions et surtout
dans la perspective électorale à venir
leur vision trois axes majeurs sont
ressortis de ces échanges tout d'abord
l'autorité de l'état
on va dresser un court bilan cette
autorité des forces de l'ordre prises
pour cibles des peines de prison non
exécutées une progression de l'islamisme
une immigration hors de contrôle et des
zones de non droit voilà le bilan qu'on
peut dresser aujourd'hui de l'autorité
de l'état ainsi pour la france il faut
restaurer l'autorité de l'état une
autorité qui passe d'abord par la
garantie de l'application et de
l'exécution des peines de prison puis
par le respect des forces de l'ordre et
des élus qui sont le ciment de notre
nation ainsi nous pourrons protéger
dignement l'ensemble de la population
ensuite la souveraineté tant économique
que migratoires pour la france qu'il
faut retrouver notre souveraineté
souveraineté économique bien sûr mais
aussi migratoire cette dernière
nécessitant une stricte maîtrise de nos
frontières
notre souveraineté économique aussi donc
elle exigerait une vraie volonté
politique de moderniser nos industries
stratégiques afin de rejoinder grands
pays industriels comme l'allemagne et
enfin la protection des plus fragiles en
effet ça fait vraiment partie de la kz2
protéger et on oublie peut-être trop
souvent le bilan est clair les aides
sociales massives et encore un grand
nombre de nos concitoyens qui sont dans
des difficultés lourdes pour la france
il faut donc protéger les plus fragiles
nous le savons nous sommes très généreux
parfois trop mais c'est notre devoir
envers nos concitoyens et parce que
c'est notre devoir il nous appartient de
veiller à une meilleure distribution
pour une meilleure efficacité certaines
allocations mérite d'être réformé ainsi
par exemple nous proposons chez les
républicains que l'allocation adulte
handicapé devra et aides versées en
fonction des revenus de la personne
handicapée indépendamment des revenus de
son conjoint c'est aussi sa protégée les
publics les plus fragiles
vous l'aurez compris
le mot protéger et riche de sens est
d'une importance capitale pour notre
pays c'est bien pour cela et pour cette
raison qu'il reste un thème majeur de
notre programme merci à tous
merci quentin irène devait ski la plus
jeune conseiller régional de france 22
ans vous pouvez l'applaudir
alors maintenant vous présenter la table
ronde sur la question du rassemblement
récompenser le travail et le mérite
restaurer la cohésion nationale et
promouvoir le développement durable
vas-y rennes merci donc en effet hier
les jeunes ont échangé avec agnès est
vrai députée européenne gilles platret
maire de chalon sur saône max brisson
sénateurs pyrénées atlantiques et
virginie duby muller députés en haute
savoie sur le thème rassembler encore un
grand merci à eux pour cet échange qui
était particulièrement enrichissant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors rassemblés c'est un thème vaste
mais qui nous a permis d'échanger sur de
nombreux thèmes tels que le travail
l'écologie et la cohésion nationale le
but de rassembler c'est de rassembler
les français autour d'un nouveau projet
de société ce projet repose sur la
récompense du travail et du mérite de la
solidarité entre générations et sur la
restauration de la cohésion nationale la
protection de l'environnement ne doit
pas être promu au détriment des classes
moyennes et enfin nous défendons un
équilibre éthique et progrès technique
plus généralement rassemblés sur propose
sur 12 points récompensé le travail et
le mérite comme par exemple protéger nos
agriculteurs en faisant respecter le
coût de production des produits
agricoles sur toute la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
on a eu la chance hier d'avoir dans un
intrus dans notre atelier à un
agriculteur qui on a pu échanger
longuement site assez intéressant je le
remercie je ne sais pas si c'est dans la
salle
aider les jeunes à s'insérer dans le
monde du travail en mettant en avant
l'apprentissage l'alternance et les
formations professionnelles qui
permettent à un jeune d'être directement
au contact du monde du travail
également valoriser les seniors et
préserver les droits des retraites comme
par exemple rendre le cumul
emploi-retraite plus attractifs pour
mettre en avant le rôle des seniors dans
le monde du travail
évidemment nous avons parlé de rebâtir
l'école de la république il faut
enseigner les fondamentaux nous avons
beaucoup parlé notamment dans cet
atelier du manque de niveau chez les
jeunes à l'entrée au collège par exemple
à cause d'une baisse de l'enseignement
des fondamentaux à l'école primaire
rebâtir notre politique familiale en
rétablissant l'universalité des
allocations familiales
favoriser l'accession de tous à la
propriété en maintenant les prêts à taux
zéro pour l'accession à la propriété des
classes moyennes et nous avons
longuement échangé au sujet des tracts
sûrs territoriales qu'il est vital de
réparer
transmettre notre mode de vie et les
valeurs de la république en instaurant
un service à la nation obligatoire d'au
moins quatre mois pour tous les jeunes
soutenir évidemment la culture et le
sport qui sont des vecteurs de cohésion
d'unité au sein de notre pays et enfin
havas gagné c'est vrai nous avons
longuement discuté sur un modèle de
développement durable afin de lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
contre la pollution de l'air réduire les
déchets et préserver la qualité de l'eau
nous chez les républicains ont choisi le
développement durable plutôt que
l'écologie punitive ainsi que d' arrêter
l'hypocrisie
les centrales nucléaires et stopper la
fermeture vous l'avez compris nous
devons proposer à tous les français un
nouveau projet de société porteur
d'espoir en réparant le moteur de
l'ascension sociale et en revalorisant
travail merci à tous
[Musique]
merci merci beaucoup et rennes mathieu
tu a animé la table ronde libéré qui
inclut aussi bien la libération des
entreprises à libération fiscale mais
aussi la libération des territoires pour
se libérer finalement de l'ultra
centralisme vendus par par emmanuel
macron mathieu tu peux nous en dire un
mot merci guilhem merci christian jacob
de nous laisser nous les jeunes porter
la voix et la parole du parti merci
qu'il aime alors merci qu'il aime je
sais pas parce que 9 heures tu nous fais
quand même sur une table ronde sur
l'économie dans une soirée où il y avait
un dj et pas que du jus d'orange au bar
j'en vois encore 4,5 qui dort au fond de
la salle
donc voila merci surtout à tous ceux qui
se sont investis sur cet atelier olivier
marleix ex député de l'eure et loir
vice-président du parti sophie gaugain
vice président du parti et vice
président de la région normande et
nicolas forissier présidents de
fédérations et député de l'indre et
alexandre vincent des présidents de la
fédération du rhône et maire de rillieux
la pape ils se sont beaucoup investis
sur ce sur cet atelier ils ont beaucoup
fait beaucoup de propositions très
intéressantes et je pense qu'on peut
vraiment les remercier parce que ce sont
des élus engagés notre famille politique
et on en a tellement besoin
cet atelier nous a amenés à plusieurs
conclusions
la première c'est qu'il faut enfin
briser les chaînes qui entravent notre
économie
briser les 400000 normes qui empêche la
liberté d'agir avec une refonte complète
du code du travail
briser le rouleau compresseur des taxes
et des charges notamment avec des
baisses drastiques des impôts de
production et des droits de succession
sur les entreprises pour permettre enfin
aux entreprises d'être transmises de
génération en génération
briser aussi le poids écrasant de la
dette qui menace aujourd'hui durablement
la stabilité de l'état et notre économie
la seconde conclusion nous pousse à
faire comme nos compatriotes confiance
aux élus aux élus de terrain au maire
qui représente une structuration
importante pour la france pour notre
famille politique et qui ont la vue
damman lors de la crise du coc vide se
sont montrés à la hauteur des enjeux
quand le gouvernement 20 crânien a été
incapable de fournir masques et autres
utilités et médée matériel médical dans
cette crise qui a été très difficile
enfin le troisième conclusion nous amène
à penser que nous devons également enfin
mettre fin à l' angélisme mac revient
qui 7,9 fleurons industriels
aux capitaux étrangers
nous il nous faudra rééquilibrer les
échanges mondiaux libérer davantage à
l'intérieur nos entreprises et protéger
davantage vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
l'industrie c'est aussi un sujet clé
nous devons relancer ce moteur de
l'économie en revenant notamment de la
compétitivité aux entreprises industries
mais aussi recherche alors que
l'allemagne a dépensé 1 milliard 500
millions d'euros pour le vaccin que
l'angleterre on a dépensé 499 millions
la france d' emmanuel macron soi disant
pro vaccins dont n'a dépensé que 10 sept
est ce que c'est réellement ce que nous
voulons devenir est ce que nous voulons
devient un pays du tiers monde qui est
incapable contrairement à ses voisins
européens de développer un vaccin
mais au delà de toutes ces
problématiques la droite ne doit pas se
tromper nous ne devons pas nous tromper
l'économie n'est pas une fin en soi la
règle des 3% de maastricht n'est pas
l'horizon indépassable d'une politique
économique l'économie est un moyen un
moyen moderne pour remettre et permettre
à la france de renouer avec la conquête
avec la force de l'industrialisation le
retrouver l'innovation et surtout de
retrouver sa juste place au sommet du
monde
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur on accueille
désormais sur scène patients dauphin qui
est le responsable des jeunes
républicains du nord et qui a animé la
table ronde sur les questions
européennes et internationales à
thomassin merci ghislaine bonjour à tous
alors
lors de la table ronde sur la place de
la france dans l'europe et dans le monde
on a pu balayer plusieurs sujets
la première chose qu'on a pu comprendre
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la france a besoin
a besoin de retrouver un projet
politique d' influence non seulement à
travers l'union européenne aujourd'hui
quand on débat entre nous on se demande
quel est le projet de l'union européenne
quelle est la place de la france dans
l'union européenne le bric site a eu
lieu il ya maintenant un an je faisais
mon échappée souffle et j'ai couru
mais vient de faire le semi marathon de
paris c'est ça en fait je me suis initié
merci
mais aujourd'hui par exemple quand on
voit que le bris sites et lieux ya un an
que on n'a pas de véritable projet
politique aux seins nus européenne que
pourtant on est tous ici des jeunes on
est tous européens la plupart d'entre
nous ont fait rasmusson l'habitude de
voyager à l'étranger et pourtant
aujourd'hui quel est le projet possible
union européenne faut un projet
politique d' influence ça peut se
retrouver à travers plusieurs sujets
lors la crise sanitaire on a vu une
absence totale de coopération en matière
économique aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
peut représenter la france seule sans
l'union européenne face à la concurrence
et à la montée des tensions entre la
chine et les états unis aujourd'hui on a
besoin pour une véritable politique un
véritable projet de la même manière
quand on regarde l'état des frontières
européennes
on a un manque criant de budget sur
frontex on a un problème on a débattu
est que députée européenne nadine morano
veut là sur la directive retour on a un
problème aussi sur le conditionnement de
l'aide au développement et des laissez
passer consulaires pour les personnes en
situation régulière fin par rapport au
pays des personnes qui viennent en
situation régulière on a aujourd'hui
vraiment besoin de l'union européenne
pas forcément d'une union européenne
fédérale je pense que sur ce on est tous
d'accord mais d'une europe l'union
européenne politiques qu'ils soient
concrètes
ils se retrouvent dans le quotidien des
gens qui puissent leur changer d'avis et
qui est vraiment réussissent à toucher
leur quotidien et qu'on puisse se dire
ah oui ça aujourd'hui c'est union
européenne et pas uniquement un petit
encart avec des financements quand on a
des projets qui sont financés
ensuite on a pu aussi voir que la france
à travers la franconie à la francophonie
avec une langue qui est quand même saleh
qui est la deuxième langue parlée dans
le monde a besoin aussi de retrouver un
vrai projet politique aujourd'hui on n'a
pas conscience mais en tant que français
c'est une véritable chance et on doit
aussi pouvoir s'en servir pour avoir une
stratégie d' influence que ce soit
évidemment sur le continent africain
mais également dans d'autres pays je
pense aussi au fait qu'on soit présent
sur tous les continents
aujourd'hui on a aussi besoin de se
servir la francophonie non seulement à
travers une stratégie d'influencé dans
le monde mais également pour ne pas
laisser l'anglais s'est imposé comme
seule langue
comme seule langue ou au sein de l'union
européenne et pouvoir enfin être fiers
les français est fier de parler le
français
et enfin on avait pu lui aussi
débattre de tensions économiques entre
la chine et les etats unis pour pouvoir
retrouver une véritable influence et
c'est à peu près tout je pense
[Applaudissements]
merci bastien merci à rennes merci
mathieu merci content vous pouvez encore
une fois les applaudir très très fort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant sur scène théo
michel secrétaire général des jeunes
républicains et marie glinel président
du cercle athéna
[Musique]
à
je tiens encore y croire
merci christian jacob le président des
républicains car c'est grâce à lui que
ces propositions des jeunes républicains
ces seize propositions des républicains
des jeunes républicains seront
incorporés dans le programme des
républicains pour la présidentielle
merci président boureux confiance
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous
donc je vais comme les autres l'ont fait
donc remercier notre président parce que
c'est assez évident de le faire puisque
c'est le premier à nous donner autant de
place à nous les jeunes dans le
déploiement de nos idées aussi librement
et rien que pour ça on peut le remercier
parce que c'est assez on va dire rare
pour le souligner bravo à vous tous
d'être ici si nombreux évidemment parce
que c'est assez surprenant vu l'énorme
ambiance dersoir de se retrouver aussi
frais et dispos ce matin pour parler
programme
et enfin merci à guilhem carayon qui est
nôtre reiss à nous qui c'est nous qui
sait nous nous guider qui arrive à
naviguer avec nous vers justement une
nouvelle ère pour les jeunes merci aux
veines qui a su organiser cet événement
avec autant d'énergie
donc on est là pour présenter les
propositions des jeunes républicains
alors ces propositions des jeunes
républicains ont été générés par le
cercle athena qui est le cercle de
réflexion des jeunes républicains qui
est un espace à la fois d'expression et
de considération ou les jeunes
républicains prennent le temps de
réfléchir et de faire mûrir leurs idées
précisément parce que la pensée n'émerge
que sur le temps long et pas dans la
précipitation n'en déplaise à la start
up nation nous sommes là pour travailler
justement sur ces question donc de
projet et j'ai acquis du coup la
certitude en travaillant avec vous tous
que notre génération est plein de
vitalité
nous n'avons pas peur des idées nous
n'avons pas peur des mots et nous
n'avons pas peur de les défendre quoi
qu'il en coûte heures et c'est bien ça
qui va singulariser notre génération
c'est de défendre quoi qu'il en coûte
nos idées
nous sommes aujourd'hui 1500 1600 1700
pour justement célébrer la droite et la
france
et c'est là aussi que nous montrons la
france entière que nous sommes le parti
de la jeunesse n'en déplaise à ce
président qui veut repartir pour cinq
saisons alors que sa série n'est même
plus regardable par la france entière
esafe aux camelots souligné
[Musique]
nous avons envoyé une consultation
justement pour ce sont des veaux idées
pour voir où vous en êtes au niveau de
votre identité intellectuelle et nous
avons pu voir que d'à travers 65
question très différentes nous avons
posé une question qui nous paraissait
essentiel c'était la valeur la plus
fondamentale pour vous et nous sommes
heureux et fiers de vous dire que à plus
de la moitié donc d'entre vous le mot
liberté le mot liberté est arrivée en
tête donc de vos valeurs fondamentales
et donc ça c'est déjà énorme suivi du
mérite et donc c'est là aussi qu'on se
rend compte que vous êtes une jeunesse
qui a envie de se bouger pour son avenir
qui a envie de se mobiliser et donc bien
pour ça vous peut être fier de vous
parce que vous représentez cette droite
là et ça c'est pas mal déjà
alors juste un tout petit mot sur la
méthode donc athéna regroupe 400 jeunes
qui se sont inscrits dans différents
groupes thématiques dont 400 jeunes
qu'ils font vraiment phosphorer leur
leur cerveau et ça fait du bien aussi de
voir qu'ils en ont envie et qu'ils en
ont besoin kate sont jeunes répartis sur
14 thématique gérés par des responsables
de folie que j'aime et que je veux
remercier c'est ce soir enfin ce matin
par dont
ils ont encadré ces travaux avec un brio
remarquable et donc bravo à eux nous
avons nous sommes partis dont une
analyse fine de la réalité pour ne pas
mystifier le réel qui nous entoure et
pour se focaliser sur le réel justement
pour lutter contre le relativisme de la
vérité nous avons ensuite confronté
quand nous avons eu le temps de faire
toutes ces idées là donc à des experts
et des élus pour enfin justement faire
émerger des solutions plutôt ambitieuse
moderne et inédite donc aujourd'hui ce
matin avec toi michel mon ami théo le
lien vous présentait donc les seize
propositions
que nous voulons détaillé donc dans le
programme présidentiel
donc il ya quatre thèmes formation la
cohésion nationale l'emploi et le
régalien donc nous allons commencer par
le thème de l'éducation
comment on fait un
bond nous avons fait une consultation
quand je voulais dit alors sur la
consultation nous avons posé une
question sur l'ascenseur social vous
êtes quand même une minorité à penser
qu'il ne fonctionne pas mais c'est déjà
quand même assez inquiétant c'est pour
ça qu'on le remarque le programme
quelqu'un va vraiment accès c'est
proposition à dieu
la deuxième question concerne
l'éducation c'est la valorisation des
formations professionnelles alors vous
allez me dire quel intérêt de partager
un résultat aussi stalinien alors
effectivement ça peut poser question
mais en même temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais en même temps je suis très heureuse
d'abord que vous êtes extrêmement
majoritairement d'accord du coup pour
valoriser les formations
professionnelles bon alors le thème de
l'éducation c'est un thème qui est cher
à la droite évidemment est d'ailleurs
notre parrain françois-xavier bellamy
que je remercie ici aussi en a fait donc
un manifeste de trente propositions
sortie le 2 septembre justement sur
l'état d'urgence éducative c'est aussi
un thème qui m'est cher puisque depuis
dix ans que je s'engager à lui ni aux
républicains j'ai pu donc forcément à
l'uni aussi développer cette thématique
qui m'est extrêmement cher
donc au niveau de l'éducation nous avons
quatre propositions comme pour tous les
thèmes
voilà alors la première proposition va
s'axer sur l'orientation nous voulons
mettre en place un réel service public
de l'orientation dès le collège alors
dès le collège pourquoi parce que c'est
au collège finalement que l'on s'oriente
vers l'apprentissage soit valeur
générale
donc premièrement nous voulons créer un
module d'orientation professionnelle
justement pour éviter le taux d'échec
cuisant du début de l'université ou bien
lors le trop peu d'élèves qui se
consacrent finalement une formation en
apprentissage donc nous voulons créer ce
module d'orientation dès le collège pour
faire un stage de minimum une semaine à
la fois dans un métier de la voie
professionnelle et dans un métier d'une
voix plus générale pour vraiment faire
son choix donc ça c'est la première sous
proposition la deuxième c'est le duo
d'orientation beaucoup plus audacieux
nous voulons jouer sur la
complémentarité entre l'efficacité d'un
professionnel et la disponibilité dont
conseillers d'orientation pour justement
arrivé à dynamiser et concrétiser
l'orientation pour les jeunes notre but
ça serait de faire donc un duo entre un
conseiller d'orientation et un
représentant du monde socio économique
tu voyais l'idée donc ça c'est pour la
première proposition la deuxième
proposition qui m'est particulièrement
cher c'est la création du statut
d'ambassadeur d'excellence dans les
territoires
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que 52%
des jeunes issus de milieux ruraux
s'autocensurent pour faire des études
alors que c'est le cas pour seulement 33
% d'élèves issus de milieux urbains et
moi je suis quand même assez scandalisé
de voir qu'un gamin qui vient la
campagne pour le dire crûment mais comme
c'est le cas pour la majorité d'entre
nous s'autocensurer nous sont pas
capables de faire des études ça me
scandalise véritablement parce qu'on se
rend compte finalement que ce n'est pas
le déterminisme social qui va primer ici
mais plutôt un déterminisme géographique
et quoi qu'il en coûte nous sommes le
parti de tous les territoires et nous
l'avons prouvé nous devons développer
une politique d'information dans les
territoires et justement lutter contre
ce déterminisme géographique c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous voulons créer
ce statut ambassadeur d'excellence dans
les territoires où les étudiants qui
vient justement de milieux ruraux irez à
la rencontre de leurs collègues avaient
un des collégiens et lycéens de leur
territoire on va leur montrer qu'il est
possible de faire des études et qu'il ne
faut pas s'autocensurer leur donner
envie de se bouger dès le collège
justement pour atteindre cet objectif
donc cette proposition nous tient
véritablement à coeur ensuite concernant
la laïcité nous voulons mettre en place
un enseignement pratique de la laïcité
et j'insiste sur le mot pratiquer
pratiquer pourquoi parce que notre but
c'est d'enseigner très tôt et très
concrètement les principes et la
construction la laïcité d'une part mais
surtout à travers l'apprentissage de
comportement licites et illicites de la
religion en société dans l'espace public
et à l'école donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous voulons accorder à
l'enseignement moral et civique cette
cet élan on va dire concret et pratique
de l'apprentissage très concret donc des
comportements des sites illicites et
enfin dernière proposition celle ci vise
à valoriser donc l'apprentissage et vous
avez vu que vous étiez 99,6 % donc à
vouloir le valoriser donc ça fait
plaisir de voir comment jeu sur un sujet
on est parfaitement d'accord on ce
qu'est le cas de beaucoup de sujets
quand même donc nous voulons créer un
groupe interministériel des formations
alors pourquoi parce que finalement
aujourd'hui nous avons un déséquilibre
pathologique dans la répartition des
élèves entre les formations pro et
général et je vous parle en connaissance
de cause puis connaisseurs où je suis
élue je me rends compte qu'on ne fait
jamais jamais jamais de travaux
interministériels et c'est dommageable
les ministères travaillent de manière
très indépendante c'est la raison pour
laquelle entre d'une part
l'apprentissage qui est complètement
discrédité et qui nous donne envie qu'à
7 % des élèves et de l'autre côté
l'enseignement supérieur qui est
complètement survalorisé et qui pourtant
abouti à 60 % d'échec en première année
nous sommes dans une impasse c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous devons être le
parti qui donne du sens à la liberté de
choix de son avenir et justement par là
créer un groupe interministériel qui
travaillera précisément à l'axé
équilibré et coordonnée aux formations
ainsi qu'au contenu plus
interdisciplinaire pour justement
croiser la formation apprentissage à la
formation générale et enfin une
mutualisation des lieux de vie pour
justement n'ont pas croisé seulement les
cerveaux mais aussi les vie quotidienne
est donc partagé des campus partager des
lieux de vie donc où on apprend donc je
vous remercie donc pour ces questions
sur l'éducation nous allons passer à
théo qui lui va nous parler donc des
questions économiques merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup marie merci à tous merci
au président jacob et à madame la vice
présidente jeune garde de votre présence
et de notre écoute évidemment on est
très heureux de vous présenter ce projet
que nous avons travaillé tout l'été je
vais donc vous parler de du thème numéro
trois du travail de l'attractivité
économique et du chômage des jeunes
nous avons sondé également les jeunes
républicains au travers du sondage
envoyé par le cercle de réflexion athéna
sur sur les questions économiques nous
vous avons posé la question que pensez
vous des 35 heures vous êtes pour le
maintien des 35 heures seulement à 21,4
pour cent ne vous êtes opposé évidemment
au maintien des 35 heures en france vous
êtes pour un allongement de la durée
légale du travail à 54,6 % et qu'il n'y
ait aucune durée légale fixée par la loi
vous êtes pour cette mesure à 24%
également la question vous sentez vous
concerné est protégé par l'état sur vous
vos données personnelles vous êtes
évidemment vous ne sentez pas protégé
vis-à-vis de cela à 75,1 % et donc oui à
24 9% et c'était un sujet évidemment
très important qui n'est malheureusement
pas souvent mis sur le devant de la
scène et pourtant la cybersécurité est
un des enjeux majeurs du 21ème siècle
première proposition la simplification
du code du travail la suppression
des 35 heures est une véritable réforme
de la représentativité des syndicats au
sein des entreprises nous souhaitons
permettre aux entreprises de fixer elle
même paraît fort par référendum interne
le temps de travail qu'elles
appliqueront sans accord des syndicats
nous souhaitons passer le seuil des
obligations syndicale au sein des
entreprises qui est actuellement à 50
salariés nous voulons monter ce seuil de
représentation syndicale à 250 ce qui
créerait entre 70 et 140 mille emplois
selon l'insee nous souhaitons également
un référendum sur les scènes sur le
financement des syndicats nous voulons
la suppression de tous les financements
publics des syndicats nous voulons un
financement par le biais de cotisations
des adhérents et par un chèque syndical
de 50 roh qui serait financé à 50% par
le salarié 50% par l'employeur et enfin
nous souhaitons limiter à deux le nombre
de mandats syndicaux dans le temps et
que seulement 30% du temps de travail
soit consacré aux heures de délégation
je vois déjà jean luc mélenchon dans la
rue mais c'est pas bien grave on est
peut-être là aussi pour ça
[Applaudissements]
la deuxième mesure concerne évidemment
les jeunes et l'aide aux jeunes à
s'insérer dans le monde du travail nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui par dont
19,5 pour cent de chômage pour les 15 24
ans en france c'est seulement 6% en
allemagne nous souhaitons instaurer un
dispositif zéro charges patronales pour
tout recrutement d'un apprenti est
exonéré les charges sociales pendant six
mois pour le premier emploi d'un jeune
nous souhaitons également créé un prêt
bancaire spécifique pour les jeunes une
garantie par l'état et les régions pour
leur permettre de se lancer et créer
leur activité
la troisième proposition sur l'activité
économique ça concerne évidemment la
cybersécurité nous souhaitons former
véritablement les entreprises par la
chambre du commerce et la cci la chambre
du commerce et de l'industrie et par l'
agence annecy pour véritablement relevé
la la la la protection des données les
fichiers personnels au sein des
entreprises pour qu'ensuite elle puisse
mettre en place et souscrire des
assurances privées pour des éventuels
dédommagements pour des
éventuels cyberattaques pour leurs
fichiers internes nous nous souhaitons
également à trois ans des jeux
olympiques favoriser le financement
privé du sport le sport c'est
aujourd'hui une activité économique
comme les autres nous avons nous avons
aujourd'hui beaucoup de financement
public du sport nous sommes en un énorme
retard par rapport aux autres pays
européens et nous souhaitons évidemment
fléché la fiscalité pour les entreprises
en leur accordant des crédits d'impôt si
éventuellement elle
sponsorise d'aider des clubs de sport et
nous souhaitons également la réduction
d'impôt pour beaucoup de licenciés pour
favoriser évidemment évidemment le
financement du sport par le secteur
privé
je vais passer au quatrième thème de
cette présentation des présentations des
jeunes au ive tél 4 au quatrième thème
marie c'est s'assimiler à la culture
française et restaurer l'autorité de
l'état nous vous avons posé de questions
à ce sujet la première question êtes
vous prêt à sacrifier c'est intéressant
une part de votre liberté pour plus de
sécurité vous êtes plutôt partagés sur
cette question ce qui prouve finalement
que vous n'êtes pas forcément
totalement prêt à
ne plus avoir de liberté pour plus de
sécurité vous êtes quand même assez
partagé vous avez répondu à 48 8% non à
cette question
donc ensuite vous nous avons posé une
autre question très intéressante sur
l'espace schengen qui est un sujet de
fracture quand même chez les jeunes
républicains il faut quand même l'avouer
vous avez répondu est-ce que quelle est
votre opinion sur l'espace schengen vous
avez dit 30% pour la sortie de l'espace
schengen et rétablir des frontières
nationales vous êtes à 33,6 pour cent à
avoir dit que vous vouliez rester dans
l'espace schengen mais avec de
véritables modification des frontières
de l'espace schengen et une réforme de
l'agencé frontex qui l agence en charge
de l'espace schengen et vous êtes 36,4 à
rester à vouloir rester dans l'espace
schengen actuelle sans véritable
modification
nous proposons 4
4 propositions nous sommes pour
renforcer les conditions de
naturalisation et d'obtention des types
de séjours premièrement en mettant un
véritable test à la nature pour obtenir
la naturalisation
en france nous voulons modifier
l'article 21-24 du code civil et en
disant la réussite de l'évaluation donc
du test conditionnent l'obtention la
nature la nationalité française en cas
d'échec lors de l'évaluation la demande
de naturalisation n'est pas acceptée
nous souhaitons comme en grande bretagne
et en allemagne également faire d'une
condition de l'obtention d'un titre de
séjour la maîtrise de la langue
française et de l'écrit français
la deux la deuxième proposition
concernant ce thème est lié à la
garantie et à l'application de toutes
les peines prononcées aujourd'hui vous
avez environ 50 % seulement des peines
de prison qui sont prononcés qui sont
véritablement exécuté ce qui est
évidemment pas assez nous sommes pour
augmenter de 20 mille places de prison
en france pour complaire à 20000 places
de prison nous refusons évidemment la
remise dit de faveur de certaines peines
pour les violences faites contre les
élus et les forces de l'ordre nous
souhaitons durcir
nous souhaitons durcir la justice des
mineurs dès le premier délit augmenter
les places de centre éducatif fermé et
enfin un remettre la loi ciotti 2010
pour la suspension des allocations
familiales pour les parents de mineurs
délinquants multirécidivistes
[Applaudissements]
troisième proposition et nous tiennent
d'une proposition très importante qui
concerne les violences intrafamiliales
nous souhaitons nommer un gendarme
référent des violences intrafamiliales
au sein des commissariats et des
gendarmeries avec une véritable
formation des personnes au sein des
équipes qui pourrait justement
accueillir les personnes victimes de
violences notamment les femmes nous
souhaitons une prise en compte
évidemment territoriale de ses besoins
humains puisqu'on sait pertinemment que
dans certains territoires il y à plus de
violence conjugale et intrafamiliale que
dans d'autres départements et nous
souhaitons la nomination au sein du parc
et d'un référent violences
intrafamiliales pour faire le lien entre
la justice et la police
nous souhaitons et c'est la dernière
mesure sur sur les questions régaliennes
nous souhaitons systématiser les tests
osseux pour les soi-disant mineurs
isolés qui sont autour de 17 mille par
an en france ce qui crée beaucoup de
problèmes d'insécurité dans certains des
territoires nous souhaitons évidemment m
au sein de la loi l'obligation par les
juges de mettre en place un test osseux
pour véritablement savoir si nous avons
affaire à des mineurs ou finalement des
personnes qui sont majeurs et donc en
situation de clandestinité qui doivent
être expulsés du territoire national
[Applaudissements]
je vais passer à marie la parole sur les
questions de cohésion nationale
c'est à toi marie merci à tous merci
théo alors nous allons donc passer au
dernier thème sur la cohésion nationale
donc nous sommes vraiment réparti les
les thèmes en gentil méchant
annoncé des thèmes répartis
aléatoirement
donc sur la cohésion nationale nous
sommes partis de la proposition générale
des républicains qui veut instaurer un
service à la nation obligatoire de
quatre mois alors il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui dans la loi il existe
d'une part du coup le volontariat qui va
ce qui va se porter sur la défense la
solidarité et l'humanitaire nous
estimons que ces thèmes sont pas assez
exhaustif pour résoudre l'ensemble des
problèmes et de l'autre côté il ya le
service national universel obligatoire
qui lui est complètement dénuée de forme
d'obligations justement puisque il
s'agit juste du recensement et de la jop
dès que vous avez tous fait nous en
partant de là donc le parti en parlant
un partant de là donc le parti des
républicains a voulu créer un service
obligatoire à la nation lequel nous
voulons donc compléter compléter avec
trois thèmes trois parcours un parcours
électoral un parcours agricole et un
parcours patrimonial donc nous
expliquant le parcours service national
électoral donc pour éviter justement
ce flou on va dire sauf là où l'absence
de flou finalement de deux jeunes qui
vont voter donc pour éviter l'abstention
des jeunes qui atteint 72 % cette année
quand même ainsi que pour les initier à
la question de la vie citoyenne nous
voulons créer un service national
électoral justement pour les initier à
la question citoyenne donc ça c'est la
première chose
le parcours service national ricol c'est
justement
pour faire le lien entre la jeunesse et
l'agriculture qui aujourd'hui finalement
ne n'attire plus la jeunesse nous
voulons l'inscrire dans les missions
d'intérêt général pour que les jeunes
s'initient donc à la question agricole
est donc en fait un service national
agricole troisième parcours le parcours
de la rénovation du patrimoine pour les
métiers du patrimoine et donc pour les
apprentis du patrimoine le but de
valoriser donc le patrimoine à travers
une solution de rénovation novatrice et
donc justement pour rentrer dans les
budgets de l'état c'est-à-dire 0,06 %
consacrés à la rénovation du patrimoine
nous voulons
m donc les apprentis des métiers du
bâtiment en lien avec le patrimoine pour
qu'ils signent donc à la fin de leur
contrat de mission à la fin de leur
période d'apprentissage en contrats de
mission justement de rénovation du
patrimoine donc ce sont les trois
parcours que nous voulons créer donc
dans ce service national et enfin
dernière question sur la question de la
cohésion nationale notre ami on a parlé
tout à l'heure dans la restitution des
travaux c'est la question de la
francophonie notre but est de développer
les moyens consacrés à la francophonie
pour soutenir la diffusion de nos
créations artistiques alors la
diplomatie culturelle est un outil de
soft power plutôt puissant nous
souhaitons redonner à la france sa place
de leader mondial de la francophonie
c'est pour ça qu'à travers le
développement de la francophonie à
l'international nous devons soutenir
donc la diffusion de création artistique
française donc je vous remercie pour la
question donc de la cohésion
voilà pour ses seize propositions
majeures que nous souhaitons évidemment
qu'elle soit retenue pour l'élection
présidentielle pour le programme des
républicains pour pour cette échéance
majeure majeur merci à tous évidemment
je sais que vous avez énormément
contribué à l'élaboration de ce
programme je voudrais évidemment
remercié mme olga l'art je sais qu'il
est dans la salle qui est vice-président
du cercle athéna on peut l'applaudir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai juste à vous dire quelque chose
soyez libres dans la défense de vos
convictions ne soyez influencés par
personne ne soyez pas intimider soyez
fait de la politique par conviction
parce qu'à un moment donné ça paye
toujours voilà merci à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]